ce matin c'est un déménagement un peu
particulier qui se déroule par ranger le
matériel pour partir les ordinateurs les
tablettes vidéoprojecteur et puis les
claviers et c'est parti pour une drôle
de transhumance d'ordinateurs à travers
la campagne charolaise abords du digital
trucks destination charolles pour
l'installation de l'atelier de formation
alors donc aujourd'hui on va partir sur
l'organisation des fichiers et des
dossiers il ya nice et amélie sont
formateurs ils sont salariés de
l'association syntaxe erreur 2.0 l'idée
du camion est d'amener le numérique
directement aux usagers grâce à des
ateliers d'initiation sur des thèmes
simples la messagerie internet la
sécurité ou les démarches en ligne
on va essayer cliquez sur l'écran oui la
solution avant on a été sur les sites
pour déclarer les impôts là donc c'était
intéressant aussi quoi puisque on va
être obligés d'y passer lés personnes
notamment les personnes âgées ont
beaucoup d'appréhension par rapport aux
démarches en ligne puisque c'est tout
nouveau pour eux ils ont besoin
effectivement qu'on les accompagne au
niveau de la de l'ordinateur pour leur
montrer comment comment cela fonctionne
et qui puisse être après autonome
les participants et participantes ont
été invités à ces ateliers par leur
caisse de retraite complémentaire
aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est comment
les retraités peuvent rentrer en contact
avec la caisse de retraite
complémentaire
souvent aujourd'hui on leur demande
allez chercher votre attestation fiscale
créer votre espace client aujourd'hui
sur ce public là c'est sûr que beaucoup
ont des ordinateurs des tablettes
mais ne savent pas forcément faire des
démarches en ligne auto le carnet du
digital troc est bien rempli pour les
seniors comme pour les jeunes les
missions locales pôle emploi sont très
demandeurs si le camion ne se déplacent
pour l'instant que dans huit villes du
charolais l'association ne manque pas
d'idées
un projet de créer un deuxième digital
trucks est donc d'aller sur le
territoire toujours que le territoire
charlet brionnais mais d'aller dans les
combines un peu plus petit d'aller
directement à proximité des gens depuis
le lancement du digital troc cet été
près de 200 personnes ont bénéficié
d'une initiation au numérique
[Musique]